with any recurrent cases but there is no
formal system of de-escalating this
other than for whu-oh to take to change
its national global and regional risk
assessments and obviously as I said the
ihr only allows whu-oh two choices there
is either at global health public health
emergency or there is not thank you very
much next question comes from Georgia
Constantine to what Mike said with
regard to the alarm the highest level of
alarm for de blasio was actually raised
on January 30th and this is when in the
rest of the world we had only 82 cases
of cavett kovat and zero days so having
raising the alarm should be associated
actually in the highest level based on
the ihr with the january of course many
countries would like to get out of the
you know different measures that are
being taken by by the country by many
countries and that is rightly so but our
our recommendation is still the hull the
alert at any country should be at the
highest level possible and whatever
measures we take should be a very phased
one that reflects the country's
situation while investing in the
comprehensive comprehensive package that
we have been advocating for so while
opening a country still
the Arlen in each country can stay as
high as as possible and we can do
everything we can to control the V
epidemic so the two can can go together
so we will try Constantine he on a
tannish really from Georgia we try to
have you on Monday hope this time it
will be better Constantine can you hear
you can you hear us we are trying to get
in touch with bit Constantine from
Georgia yeah I am NOT okay okay thank
you thank you very much
I'm from News Agency I press G from
Georgia
Georgians is a nation have very tight
social contacts that are motivated not
only by by tradition but also by
economic necessity to live in extended
families without possibilities to
distance or isolate our social
behavioral and welfare situation are
very different to those of Sweden her
Baltic countries my question is in the
future will you issue country specific
guidelines accommodating specific social
and welfare context how in this
situation where is distant is not an
easy option we can protect the most
vulnerable groups thank you very much I
could begin on I'm Georgia I think Maria
will come in and I think you make a very
very good point in the second part of
your question around how can we ensure
that the these global guidance are
adapted into local context and it is
important that they are we have seen the
impacts of lockdown measures in in in
lower-income settings which are you know
having a deep impact on people's lives
so we have to be very very careful that
we offer advice that can be adapted at
national
and we have issued for adapting our
global guidance to refugee camps to
low-income settings to various other
settings and Maria can speak to that
guidance with the specific respect to 2
to 3 Georgia I think George has been in
a very flat growth curve over the last
couple of weeks and has obviously kept
cases down to under 650 and and has a
has a doubling time of cases of weeks
now so I think there's only been a 6%
increase in cases in the last week so I
think George itself is doing well I do
we do understand the the context in
Georgia and I was proud to serve on
epidemic response in Georgia many years
ago and have traveled throughout Georgia
and understand the the special social
and cultural context but I think Georgia
also has very strong and proud tradition
in public health and science and I'm
sure given the way the data looks like
Georgia will pull through but I do
respect the question that we must and
this is the job of national government
whu-oh can only create guidance at a
global level aimed at giving
government's to best possible scientific
evidence and options and very often you
see with our documents we call them
consideration sometimes we call them
scientific technical advice because
we're we really are conscious of is that
what science may say is the fact that
the global level must be adapted in
terms of policy to local situations and
the translation of scientific knowledge
into policy and into action
requires that this happened not only at
national level but very often at
sub-national level and the context in
some big countries is very different at
sub-national level there are different
groups different ethnic groups different
populations and therefore the constant
capacity to be able to adapt guidance to
the specific context in which our
peoples live is extremely important and
something something that's overlooked in
the process we tend to focus on the
generation of scientific evidence as the
primary job in my experience that's very
important
but the ability to adapt that evidence
and make it practical and usable at more
and more local levels especially a
community level is a great gift I think
that's been under-recognized very often
in this response and in many other
public health endeavors in the past Rhea
thanks just a supplement that to say as
mike has just said that we we develop
guidance at the global level we work at
the regional level through our regional
offices where there are some adaptations
that are made for the context of the
region we work through our country
offices where the guidance is adapted
further to the national context and we
work with ministries of health and other
partners in countries to make sure that
the guidance is adapted even further so
it takes into consideration the local
situation the capacity of the country
the economics of the country the culture
of the country and and as mike has said
that adaptation is what makes this
guidance useful having something on
paper at a global level is not the same
as taking it and putting it into a
national action plan resourcing that
ensuring that you have the right
capacities in terms of people and
products and testing and health workers
and PPE to be able to implement that and
that takes some work and that's really
important because that adaptation is
make makes it worth worth it's its
weight one thing to note though is that
the goals don't change when you adapt to
different contexts we don't change the
goal or minimize our efforts to save
lives to prevent infections that goal
remains the same regardless of where the
guidance is implemented what we have to
do is be practical and we have to find
those adaptations that make it work you
mentioned the multi-generation homes
where people are living in close contact
to one another that is common in many
parts of the world and that needs to be
taken into consideration which is why
it's so important that countries have
the ability to rapidly detect cases
and isolate those cases in healthcare
facilities and if they can't be isolated
in health care facilities they're
isolated in facilities that take them
away from the home and care for them
depending on the severity of their
symptoms and that's important because
then you remove the virus from that home
and further to that you know find the
contacts quarantine the contacts in safe
situations so just just to highlight
that we do acknowledge that what we put
out at the global level may not be
perfect for every situation and it
certainly is not but it's using the
evidence that we have and we are
constantly looking at that evidence and
we are constantly adapting our guidance
and trying to make it as most useful for
everyone across the world next question
comes from Andy independent we have BOSU
doraji on online do we have BOSU there
are you from the independent if possible
unmute please I'm sorry about that my
question is regarding the the positions
of lockdown measures in Algeria Lebanon
Southwest Iran a few other places in
recent days as well as plans to reimpose
the lockdown and Saudi Arabia later this
month of course we had the situations in
Seoul and Singapore earlier do you see
these I'm sorry if this is a rather
basic question that I'm sure you
rehashed over the recent weeks but do
you see these as anticipated and normal
and given the trajectory of this and
other pandemics do these in positions
suggest policy failures in any way are
they cautionary tales are just
understandable trial and error
um I think you answered your own
question so I think they're all of the
above
some are cautionary tales and some
represent actually the kind of things we
expect it's all about scale and it's all
about how much you understand the
problem I think if there is no question
the reason why countries have gone into
different forms of severe public health
and social measures and lockdowns
was to separate people so we could stop
the virus jumping from person to person
if the virus is still present and you
bring people closer together you don't
have to be a brains you don't have to be
an astrophysicist to work out that the
disease will move more easily from
person to person in that situation so if
you can get the day-to-day case number
down to the lowest possible level and
get as much virus out of the community
as possible then when you open you will
tend to have less transmission or much
less risk if you reopen in the presence
of a high degree of virus transmission
then that transmission may accelerate if
that virus transmission accelerates and
you don't have the systems to detect it
it will be days or weeks before you know
something's gone wrong and by the time
that happens you're back into a
situation where your only response is
another lockdown and I think word this
is what we all fear is a vicious cycle
of public health disaster followed by
economic disaster followed by public
health disaster followed by economic
disaster and I think everyone and this
sometimes there's a bit of a false
equation here I'm I'm listening and
involved in discussions all the time
where people are asking me so this is
the economy or the health system and
it's not because I think very very smart
people are saying on the economic side
that the worst thing that can happen is
if we come out of a lockdown and then we
don't do the health care right and we go
back into a lock on that
has more danger for the economic system
than it actually has with a health
system in a sense because you can
imagine that if the health system gets
time to recover then it can cope with
another rise in cases and the health
system can probably do that a few times
I'm not sure how many times the economic
system can do that so I do think this
isn't an either/or and it's really
important that we learn those lessons
now and that I think you see in cases
like particularly in Korea in China in
Germany where there's been a jump in
cases the government's there have been
alert to that happening and I've taken
very immediate action to investigate and
I think that's what we need to see when
we see that kind of Rapid Action then
were reassured and I think populations
are reassured but if we don't have those
public health surveillance systems in
place and then we start to see the
hospitals fill up again as the indicator
if we have to wait until our hospitals
are overflowing before we recognize
there's a problem then I think you're
not in to trial and error then you're in
to what you called a cautionary tale and
should we should not be waiting to see
if opening of lock downs has worked by
Counting the cases in the ICU are
counting the bodies in the mark that is
not the way to know something has gone
wrong the way to know that the disease
is coming back is to have community
based surveillance to be testing and to
know the problem is coming back and then
be able to adjust your public health
measures accordingly that does not go
back to a situation where we don't know
what's happening until our hospitals are
overflowing that is not a good way to do
business I just want to comment on the
the use of the the phrase lockdown I
think there's this misconception that
lockdown is one thing it's not it's a
set of measures that that countries have
taken
they include you know individual and
community level restrictions of
movements or some of them are called
stay at home orders
they include closures of different types
of facilities whether these are schools
or workplaces partial closed or closure
or full closure and we should say that
not all countries did school closure not
all countries close all their workplaces
they include closures of bars and and
nightclubs
they include you know restrictions or
limiting of mass gatherings and sporting
events and so this use of the word
lockdown it makes it sound like an
entire country has shut down overnight
and it's just it's just not the case so
what we're seeing in a number of
countries and and where we're seeing
more success in this and we are
constantly learning we have to keep
saying that there is no one solution
here that you must do this or you must
do that it must be a comprehensive
approach and in some countries they've
looked at the virus they've looked at
what is where is the intensity of
transmission where do we need to impose
some of these measures in terms of
restricting people's movements and and
putting stay at home orders in and where
do we need to lift them when the
situation changes and I think we we need
to get into this mindset that it's going
to take some time to come out of this
pandemic whatever that looks like
including the lifting of these measures
in a slow in a staggered way which will
differ you know based on the country
itself you may see a lifting in some
parts of the country where it's staying
in place and others and as the virus is
either controlled or it has found a
place to take off in research those
measures may need to be put in place
again and I think that having the
communities and having all of us
understand that they may need to be
lifted they may need to be implemented
again I think we need to be ready for
that and it isn't it's important that
countries have the systems in place to
be able to rapidly detect cases and then
take appropriate actions so I just
wanted to comment on the use of this
word lockdown because it isn't an
all-or-nothing and we need to find the
new normal as we go forward in managing
the risk of resurgence and protecting
people's health while getting people
back to living their daily lives
thank you
a few of you were asking about a
background noise that was rain it's just
stopped now but it can come again so
it's just terrain and next question is
for Shane shoe from CCTV Shane can you
hear us right thank you
and hear me yes thank you - great Shane
from China to television CCTV in most
taste of United States at least one
third of Kobe 19 bass are from the
long-term care facilities how could this
happen or is it because of the idea of
herd immunity that was talked a
discussed before in the previous
briefing or there's lack of the care for
this one or group thank you yeah I think
the the issue of deaths and covered 19
and one care facilities is a phenomenon
that's unfortunately happened all over
the world and many many countries have
been affected by this around the world
and in in that sense it is a it is a
tragedy we've spoken about that many
times there are many obviously factors
driving mister the population of people
who live in long-term care settings are
very often older and have many many many
have underlying conditions so there are
very very vulnerable community from that
perspective and the the long-term care
sector is not like the hospital sector
it's it's you know people are living in
very many different types of settings
it's not around the world it's not a
standardized setting and and some long
term care facilities kind of many many
residents who have been served by a
relatively small number of staff who may
or may not have
lots and lots of training and health
care provision and infection prevention
and control and those standards would
vary greatly from country to country but
I think the one thing that most
countries would accept in is that we
haven't managed to shield those centers
from disease entering and when the
disease has entered those long-term care
facilities it has been extremely
difficult to prevent the spread in those
facilities and the loss of our wisest
people have died in that and I think
this is something that's going to have
to be dealt with as countries now emerge
from a high incidence phase because the
not only is it a tragedy that that this
disease is occurring and killing so many
people in those facilities if that
disease remains in those facilities it
will come back out into communities
through the workers who work there and
families who visit the DGA said no one
is safe until everyone is safe so we do
have a duty of care to care for and
protect our most vulnerable our wisest
our most cherished citizens and we also
need to take this on because we want our
communities will not be safe in many
countries where over fifty percent of
all the cases have been in long-term
care facilities and I can tell you
that's a long list of countries if you
measure how many countries in this
response of more than 50% of their cases
in long-term care facilities but we also
have long-term issues to face in terms
of how we are providing care for our
older citizens and how that is delivered
and how that is paid for and how safe
and how appropriate that is so that's a
bigger discussion for another day but
it's one that will have to happen but
for now we need to shield those those
very vulnerable people and we need to be
sure that we pick up these diseases it's
a bit we were discussing earlier today
with our colleagues who work in the NGO
sector but refugee camps when we spoke
historically how one case of measles are
one case of meningitis and refugee camp
is an emergency because the consequence
of not reacting to that first case are
so catastrophic we need to have that
view when it comes to respiratory
disease in long-term care facilities and
I think there may be a degree of
complacency that if someone has a
respiratory disease and their long-term
care facility well that's persons just
old or that may or may not be cool but I
think we have to have a high index of
suspicion and I think we need to be very
reactive and I think we need to provide
support to to those facilities and I've
seen some very good examples of
hospitals local hospitals twinning and
providing direct support to long-term
care facilities to support their
infection prevention and control to have
more access to doctors and nurses to
come and help them make diagnosis to
have more rapid testing available and
prioritize for long-term care facilities
there are the things we can do
immediately in order to address the
immediate needs but I do think in the
long term we will have to look at how we
provide care and support for our as I
said our older and most cherished
citizens quickly and we do have guidance
out on long-term care facilities but the
the critical factor is to prevent the
virus from entering into a system into
the into this closed setting as they're
known in the sense that people live in
one building and facility what the goal
is is to prevent the virus from entering
in and to help these facilities to have
a risk assessment based approach to say
what is our risk of having this virus
introduced and if it is what do we do
what is our plan to be able to protect
the residents of these long-term
facilities how do we protect the workers
who work there and part of that is
looking at infection prevention and
control within that facility ensuring
that the workers who are there are
trained that the residents are familiar
with what kovat is and how they can
protect themselves and ensuring that the
the right prevention and control
measures are in place as you've
highlighted that this is a persistent
problem in many countries and is
something that we really need to find
ways to better support countries in this
but but not only that we need to also
ensure that the people who are living in
these facilities also have the right
clinical care for their chronic
conditions so that that is maintained so
that they have the right psychosocial
support as
they're going through this some people
who are living in long-term care
facilities are at the end of life stage
and we need to make sure that they still
have access to their families and their
loved ones as they're going through that
and so there's a balance that needs to
be to be taken into account but we must
protect people who are living in
long-term care facilities and we must
make sure that the guidance that we do
have is used and to find ways to adapt
that to the different settings so that
we protect people who are living in
these facilities next question is for FA
News Agency Isabelle yes thank you for
taking my question is there are some
countries that did not great to have too
many cases of to look down and I can
make two examples Russia has had six
week of block lockdown and there were
eight weeks up to now but in most
countries cases sit in prison and in the
world my question to you is why is
lockdown which were quite strict didn't
work for them and how much of the
outcomes depend on government or state
responsibility how much of individual
responsibility so I can start I don't I
don't know the specifics about the
implementation of public health and
social measures and Russia and Peru off
the top of my head but what we can say
is the virus needs people to transmit
between if people are in close contact
with one another and you have an
infected person it will transmit to
another person through these respiratory
droplets and so everything that we can
do to prevent that from happening where
we know this virus is we need to one
look for it so that we know where the
measures need to be put in place
but if the virus is spreading when there
are measures in place that we need to
assess that and that needs to be this is
this is why we mentioned looking at a
comprehensive approach and taking a
data-driven approach look at the
epidemiology in the situation and in the
geographic context of where it is break
that down to the lowest administrative
level as you can look at which
interventions are being used how they
are being implemented and see if there's
any any cracks there if there's any ways
in which that could be done better or
that could be done differently and we
need to learn from that and I think that
will help understand you know why is the
virus taking off in certain situations
in certain contexts in certain
communities and and because we I say
that because we know what has worked in
some areas we know what has worked and
that includes finding cases isolating
those cases finding the contacts
quarantine in the contacts by doing that
you're actually breaking the chains of
transmission
you're breaking the opportunity from an
infected person to pass to another
person and so the interventions that are
put in place need to have that in mind
may I just add I did speak the other day
about the the rapid increase in the
number of cases in in the Russian
Federation and obviously the situation
there is is developing equally with
regard to Peru there's been nearly a 50%
increase in cases in in the last in the
last week and Peru's a relatively small
country is now up to nearly I think at
67 or 68 thousand cases there and
they've been quite a number of cases
amongst health workers in Peru as well I
think 1,600 health workers have been
infected and a lot of infections amongst
police officers and others and we've
seen that in other countries are the
first responders and the frontline
workers are very often the ones exposed
to the virus and it's some of the
success of implementing
at home orders and movement restrictions
have related to how quickly it was done
and when it was done and a difference of
two weeks in those stay at home orders
could make a big difference in the in
the epidemiology it also depends to what
extent countries had good surveillance
in place and then added public health
and social measures to that as opposed
to having very little in place in terms
of public health surveillance and then
having to put the lock downs in place to
try and suppress the disease spread
there is some magical thinking going on
that lockdowns work perfectly and that
unlocking lock downs will go great
both are fraught with dangers just
putting in place whinging lock downs can
do as much harm as good if it's not done
as Maria said carefully you choose the
measures you want to put in place that
are adapted to your social and societal
needs that are adapted to stopping the
virus most effectively from what you
understand as the transmission of virus
in your community what measures can you
use that are adapted and acceptable and
implementable and sustainable in
communities in order to stop the virus
and then whatever risk is left and there
will be risk left you managed with
surveillance and response that is a risk
management approach we've said it since
the beginning a comprehensive strategy
based on measures to mitigate the spread
and suppress the spread of the virus and
measures to pick up and respond to cases
the two together with the well empowered
involved an educated community I think
we've seen again and again in a large
number of countries they've made that
work other countries haven't yet quite
made that work we all need to get on
that journey but I do think that when we
say lockdowns didn't work it may be a
timing issue it may be a fact that
people were not on board with the
processes may be the wrong measures were
chosen and weren't adapted to their
social context so I think it's hard to
say that but I think we need to be very
very careful in also saying that if
lockdowns didn't work then taking away
lock downs will work they're not the
same
the next question is Stephen from a BBC
world Stephen Schneider if I'm not wrong
Stephen can you hear us
yes I can't anymore me yes very good
this is about this the question about
the numbers of test kits in Yemen the on
April 21st reuters reported that the
international initiative on kovat 19 in
Yemen was sending a shipment that
contained tens of thousands of test kits
the article said that the IIC Y was
working with the United Nations this
week I learned from a who Stafford that
there were eight hundred three tests
that had been conducted countrywide in
Yemen so far so my question is why have
so few coronavirus tests been completed
in Yemen
I have to get back you on the number of
test kits that have been shipped to him
and I don't have that data with me I do
know as of the 9th of May we have 35 lab
confirmed cases and seven deaths in
Yemen and and we and the UN are
operating under the assumption that the
virus is circulating widely and
undetected and in local communities
since the second of May we've seen a
fivefold increases and while we may you
know increasing from 7 to 35 cases may
not seem like much we've seen that
before very very slow low level
incidents followed by a rapid escalation
everyone starts at zero or one it's
where you go after that that matters and
we do see worrying trends there we have
not suspended any other operations at
the moment but we are greatly curtailed
in our movements in the country first
security reason we're also trying to
increase our footprint but that also
involves the rest of the UN decreasing
footprint because there are limitations
on the number of UN staff that can be
in-country
so responding to COBIT effectively means
not responding to other things and we
thank our colleagues in the UN and the
leadership for visa grande the
humanitarian coordinator there for
facilitating and coordinating a process
by which we can have more boots on the
ground the the we would like to see more
testing but to do more testing you also
have to have access to healthcare
facilities you have to have workers who
can do that testing you have to be able
to train people to do that you have to
be able to do waste management it is
exceptionally difficult to deliver
services in the context of Yemen a
fractured state with multiple different
warring parties but as I say I will come
back to you on the number of tests
shipped I'm sorry I don't have that
information of hand and with any further
information on plans to scale-up testing
across the country
we'll take one or two more questions
Carl from Aard Carl Maurer hello Carl
can you unmute yourself please hello yes
and you near me yes um this is Carolyn
speaking from worlds
alfe alert crisis and good afternoon I'd
like to ask you what are the risks do
you think of the UK having eased
lockdown with people going back to work
public transport quite crowded and shops
starting to open before having
implemented a full tracking and tracing
system or do you think that they have
already thank you thank you Karen and
we'll try to go to Carl is the last
question so it comes to you okay yeah
thank you just respond to this question
and it will come back to you okay thank
you
oh yeah waiting sorry okay DeeDee says
that go ahead ask your question so we'll
then have two in a row Charles please go
ahead okay I wonder if we can talk about
its cushions
if closed borders had an effect on
slowdowns spreading new virus especially
as states like Germany Switzerland
Austria are known what plan to reopen
and I wanted to know are there any
recommendations what should states keep
in mind when we opening borders when
reactivating travel
I think this is a major consideration I
think those two questions what about the
UK one about borders think the borders
one has more general relevance and will
to answer that well first and then come
back to the specific UK one I think
there are both land and air borders and
obviously crossing a land border in
itself doesn't present a tremendous
amount of risk because the conveyancer
is usually a kara so it's a person
moving from one zone to the other and I
think a lot of countries now are looking
at risk and response in koalas ation
they're looking at other countries are
saying is the risk of disease in your
country similar to mine and is your
response comprehensive like mine so if
we exchange citizens or tourists there's
no real difference if a person from a
country that's managing risk well and
managing responds well can move between
countries then you're not adding any
extra risk by moving your citizens
between the countries and in that sense
you see countries in the Baltic like
Latvian Lithuanian looking at what they
call bubble travel zones I think
Australian New Zealand
doing the same I think countries in the
ASEAN are doing the same and looking at
how and I think that's maybe how travel
and trade will will return I'm not an
economist and I'm not a futurist but I
think you're going to see countries in
the same sub regions or regions
particularly those with land borders or
strong traditional trading or historical
links are going to look for ways to
equalize the risk bring their responses
into line so that they have the
confidence of their communities that the
risk in that country and the response in
that country is very similar to what we
have here and therefore we can move as
citizens between so that's going to take
time but I sense that's the way it's
going to happen air travel is a
different challenge because air trouble
can bring people a very long way and
around the world literally in half a day
or a day and making and that's going to
introduce more complexity for countries
as regards their rules they will have
for arrivals from far away and that's
going to involve much more sophisticated
risk manager
and risk reduction measures both in
terms of which countries can travel to
which and then how the airline process
of the travel process is managed and I
think a lot of airlines now and we're
working with our we're working with ICAO
on guidelines for how airlines can
resume in a safe in a safe manner and
that risk has to be managed right away
through the airport process the travel
process and then the immigration and
arrival process was not just being on
the plane
it's it's a long it's a long procedure
so we are working to try and advise the
travel industry how to do that as safely
as possible but again this comes back to
national policy and obviously nation
states will decide who can travel to and
from their countries and they will need
to do that both at their land borders
and that their air borders and the
arrangements made and those two
situations may differ greatly and we may
see return of land border travel a
certainly extensive cross-border travel
before we see extensive air travel but
that again remains to be seen and ok
question sure I'll take the first
question so is the question was
specifically about the UK but I'm going
to answer this question for all
countries because there is this is
consistent for every country across the
world and there are six criteria that
countries need to take into account when
they are considering adjusting their
public health and social measures or
so-called lockdowns
we've already discussed that lockdowns
can mean a number of different measures
the first criteria and the DG has said
this several times in his speeches is
that transmission is controlled that
means that the incidence of cases the
number of new cases that are happening
is reducing and that is reducing over a
period of time second is that sufficient
health systems and public health
capacities are in place that means that
countries have the workforce and the
ability to detect to test to isolate to
care for cases making sure that the
hospital facilities have enough beds to
be able to care for patients to
the severity of their symptoms to have
the right kinds of ICU facilities or
advanced care facilities respiratory
support having health care workers that
are in place that can actually care for
patients to ensure that they have
ability to contact trace the contacts of
known cases and they have the ability to
quarantine those contacts in safe
facilities the third is to make sure
that the risks of outbreaks and high
vulnerable settings are minimized
we spoken about some of these today the
the DG mentioned prisons and detention
centers in his speech today we've talked
about long-term care facilities it's
very important that there are systems in
place to protect vulnerable settings the
fourth is that workplace preventive
measures are established we've also
issued guidelines around workplace and
the resumption of work in a safe way so
that certain control and prevention
measures are in place like physical
distancing for example and that cont
workplaces have plans to be able to
rapidly identify cases and manage those
patient's cases five the risks of
imported cases are managed Mike just
described how with borders opening and
people being able to move that we it can
even be within a country that we are
able to find the virus so that the risk
of the virus moving from one geographic
area to another can be traced can be
tracked and we can break those chains of
transmission and lastly that communities
are fully engaged these are informed
empowered knowledgeable community
members who understand how the lifting
of these measures needs to take place
and a cop in a control and a slow way
and so that they understand that they
may may be able to lift them we may need
to impose them again and that we are
listening to our communities we are
working with our communities so that
they know what role each individual has
to play in controlling and suppressing
this virus
and we will go to the last question for
today and that's enough farce from
Reuters enough good afternoon
another question on the potential
longevity I understand that chief
scientist of the w-h-o spoke today to
the FT about having to is going to take
four to five years before the virus is
under control and that seems to me like
a sea change in people's expectations
because I think most people think will
muddle through until there's a vaccine
and that will take 12 months is this
view of the chief scientist something
held widely within the w-h-o thank you I
would love to see what the serious
commentary was but I suspect it was an
answer to probably a question about how
long could this last as opposed to how
long do you predict it will last we have
a new virus entering the human
population for for the first time and
therefore it is very hard to predict
when we will we will prevail over us
what is clear and I think maybe what
assume you may have been alluding to is
that the current zero prevalence of the
current number of people in our
population who've been infected is
actually relatively low and if you're a
scientist and you project forward in the
absence of a vaccine and you try and
calculate how long is it going to take
for enough people to become infected so
that this disease he settles into an
endemic phase and we may never I think
it's important to to put this on the
table this virus may become just another
endemic virus in our communities and
this virus may never go away
HIV has not gone away we've come to
terms with the virus and we have found
the therapies and we found the
prevention methods and people don't feel
as scared
as they did before and we're offering
life to people with HIV long healthy
lives to people with HIV and I'm not
comparing the two diseases but I think
it is important that we realistic and I
don't think anyone can predict when or
if this disease will disappear we do
have one great hope if we do find a
highly effective vaccine that we can
distribute to to everyone who needs it
in the world we weren't we may have a
shot at eliminating this this virus but
that fire that vaccine will have to be
available it'll have to be highly
effective it will have to be made
available to everyone and we will have
to use it before we began responding to
this event on the 31st of December we
were heavily involved that had teams in
the western Pacific working on measles
at that time every single event and if
and we've we've learned about
ventilators all of us around the world
and the last a lot of people talk about
ventilators the I think there were 14
ventilators and Westerners were more at
that time ER and all 14 were occupied by
young children and they were occupied by
young children who had a devastating
disease it was called measles and they
weren't vaccinated against that disease
so forgive me if I'm cynical but we have
some perfectly effective vaccines on
this planet that we have not used
effectively for diseases we could
eliminate and eradicate and we haven't
done it we've lacked the will we've
lacked the determination to invest in
health systems to deliver that we've
lacked the capacity to sustain primary
health care at the front end and
therefore science can come up with the
vaccine if someone's gonna make it and
we've got to make enough of it that
everyone can get a dose of it and we've
got to be able to deliver that and
people of what got to want to take that
vaccine every single one of those steps
is fraught with challenges
it's a massive opportunity for the world
the idea that a new disease could emerge
cause a pandemic and we could with a
massive moon chef
find a vaccine and give that to everyone
who needs it and stop this disease in
its tracks
will turn maybe what has been a tragic
pandemic into a beacon of hope for the
future or a planet and the way we care
for our citizens and the way we work
together to solve our problems through
solidarity through trust through working
together and through a multilateral
system that can actually benefit mankind
so I think there are no promises in this
and there are no dates this disease may
settle into a long-term problem it may
not be in some senses we have control
over that future but it's going to take
a massive effort to do what the DG's
been calling for it he's been speaking
bringing leaders together trying to
drive the issue so that we have access
to covert tools we believe we have a
coalition that can deliver on that but
it's going to need the political the
financial the operational the technical
and the community support to be a
success I just wanted to add that I
think I think many people are you know
in a state of feeling quite some despair
you know they've been they've been at
home for quite some time and they're
going through very difficult situation
they've had loved ones who have been
infected or who have died but I just
want to say that you know the trajectory
of this pandemic the trajectory of this
outbreak is in our hands and in its we
have seen in a number of countries
without medical interventions and as
Mike said we are the global community
has come together to work in solidarity
to accelerate the development of a safe
and effective vaccine and to come
together to commit to have access to
that safe and effective vaccine when it
is available but we have seen countries
bring this virus under control we have
seen countries use public health
measures the fundamentals of public
health and epidemiology and clinical
care to bring the virus under control
and to suppress transmission to a low
enough level where communities can get
back to work and communities can open up
again so we can't forget that I mean it
will take some time before we have the
information on these medical
interventions and it's coming and people
are working very hard on that
but this is in our hand and we are
seeing hope in a number of countries and
I really don't want people to forget
that
well with these comments we will
conclude today's press conference thanks
to everyone who was watching us on W Cho
social media platform also to all
journalists who were online we will have
the audio file available for you in the
next hour - and transcript tomorrow wish
everyone a very nice evening so thank
you thank you thank you Tareq and as
Maria said I think the trajector is in
our hands and this is everybody's
business and we should all contribute to
stop this pandemic and thank you for
joining and see you on Friday
you
you
you
you